Narrator: Tonight...
Our sexual desire ranges
from ice‐cold to red‐hot.
[ Laughter ]
We're talking about
a rare beauty secret called ‐‐
Shhh!
All: Shhh!
I got into this business
when I was 11.
You're a perfect example of
what every kidpreneur should do.
Corcoran: The people
that really succeed,
they have to do it
or the sky's gonna fall in.
Failure's just when you quit.
I don't quit.
[ Voice breaking ]
I will go until it succeeds.
It's not just about products.
It's about the mission.
It's about money.
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
Oh, my goodness. I can't
believe that I'm doing this.
A chick with social anxiety
about to go talk
to a couple of billionaire,
millionaires.
♪♪
Narrator: First in the Tank
is a stylish
and functional accessory.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Sofi Overton.
I'm from Vintonville, Arkansas,
and I am seeking $30,000
for 15% equity in my company.
Sharks, I'm 13 years old,
and even though
I'm still in the eighth grade,
I have a PhD in sock‐ology.
Heck, I know more
about thread counts
than I do about
the periodic table.
I created a sock for kids
made by this kid
to make life easier
for whatever we're doing.
Introducing
Wise Pocket Products,
an innovative line
of socks and leggings
with pockets in them big enough
for kids' most important items,
like your phone,
so you don't have to worry
about the life‐threatening event
of missing a call or text
from your mom anymore.
And I know what you're
probably thinking ‐‐
"There's got to be tons of socks
like this."
Well, I created
a patent‐pending sock design
for kids to safely stick
their important items
into our sock pockets.
So, if you're playing soccer...
rock climbing...
[ John laughs ]
or, you know,
spontaneously breaking out
into dance with your friends,
Wise Pocket Products
has you covered.
[ Hip‐hop music plays ]
♪♪
‐Whoa!
‐Oh!
♪♪
Nice!
‐Wow.
‐[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
O'Leary: Oh!
‐Oh!
‐Whoa!
Love you guys!
Nice!
Are you alive?
Just like my Zumba class.
I just want to
let you guys know
you're all gonna have arthritis
when you get old.
[ Laughter ]
So, as you can see, Sharks,
even after all that,
our design sock pockets will
keep your important items in
without falling out.
And the best part is, for every
pair of socks that we sell,
we donate a pair of socks
to kids in need.
Sharks, I know I'm young,
but give me five years,
and I hope I'll be sitting
in one of those chairs.
So, tell me,
who's wise enough to join me
in getting Wise Pocket Products
to kids everywhere?
Thank you for letting me
tell you about Wise,
and thanks, guys.
Cuban: Good job, guys.
‐All right, good job.
‐Good job, guys!
Excellent.
Excellent. Excellent.
You gonna show us some,
Sofi, in person here?
Yeah, sure.
♪♪
Here you go ‐‐
you can take three.
Thank you.
You did great.
O'Leary:
Thank you, Sofi.
Nice colors,
though, huh?
Cuban: Thanks, Sofi.
Overton: Thank you.
Tell us about you,
how you got into this business.
Well, I got into this business
when I was 11,
and my cousin put her phone
in her boot because, you know,
kids' and women's clothing
don't have pockets.
So I tried it, too,
and it was really uncomfortable
because it slipped
down to my ankle,
and I couldn't reach it,
and it was just,
all in all, a bad idea.
And so I asked
around my school
to see if other kids
had this problem, and they did.
And so I came up
with my prototype
where I cut off
the top of another sock
and stuck it inside the sock.
Oh, that's cool.
And then I sewed it
up the sides,
and voilà.
How did you get your money
for the business?
I save everything that I earn,
and I ‐‐
How much money did you actually
put in to make your socks?
I invested $10,000
of my own money.
$10,000? Wow!
$10,000?
I think your parents
overpaid you.
[ Laughing ] Yeah.
No, I had saved $5,000,
and I earned $5,000 more
through business pitches
and competitions like that.
John: Nice!
Oh, wow!
Wow!
Good for you!
Have you been watching
"Shark Tank" very long?
Since I was like
6 years old.
Oh, my gosh. [ Laughs ]
Yeah, make us feel old.
You know, I'd stand up
in the living room and say,
"I'm gonna be on 'Shark Tank.'"
This has been my goal
since before I even
had the idea for the business.
Have you sold any
of these yet?
Overton: Yes.
How much?
A little under $16,000
in sales.
Sofi, let me just tell you,
you're a perfect example
of what every kidpreneur
should do, right?
You got a job,
you saved up some money,
you did all the prototypes
yourself,
then you made
actual products,
then you sold those products ‐‐
$16,000 worth of products.
Now, the only question is,
did you sell those products
profitably?
Tell us what it cost you
to make a sock
and what
you're selling them for.
To make the sock,
it's $5.47.
'Cause that's expensive.
Yes.
It's because
of the process
to make the double welt
for my pocket.
What do you
sell them for?
$15 retail
and $11 wholesale.
What do you want
with the $30,000, Sofi?
What are you
gonna do with it?
Well, my main goal is
to streamline the production,
because right now,
I'm only able to produce
around 100 units per month
because I have ‐‐
Per month?
Uh, yes.
That's horrible.
So, there's other things
out there on the market
that hold in socks.
They have pockets, right?
I do have competition,
although my competitors
only have, like,
small pockets
for keys and stuff.
Well, Sofi, look,
I love what you're doing,
and it's wonderful to see this
at such a young age,
but I don't want a sock company
in my portfolio.
So I'm out.
Thank you.
Cuban: Sofi, I think
it's a great idea.
I'm gonna get some
for my kids.
For me, though, it's not
a great fit as an investment
simply because
this isn't my strength.
I couldn't tell you about
thread counts, you know.
But, I mean, congratulations.
You should be so proud.
But it's not a fit for me,
so for those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Cuban:
Congrats, though, Sofi.
Do you feel
that you want to be
running a business right now,
or is it a little stressful
when you're going to school
and all of that?
I mean, going into high school
is stressful on its own,
but with
the Wise Pocket Product,
it's kind of a boost for me.
I feel a confidence boost.
Like, if I can
own a business,
then I can go through school
and turn in that essay.
Good for you, Sofi.
Thank you.
You're already out there
hustling, thinking, creating,
doing it yourself.
So, you've got everything
that it takes
to really be
a great entrepreneur.
And Daymond and I
want to help you.
♪♪
He does quite a bit
in the sock arena,
and he would like to do
an offer with me.
I started off with Bombas,
they were doing $800,000,
and they were donating
to people,
and they donated
over 10 million pairs of socks,
and they're doing
120 million now.
And the donation is
[ Greiner laughs ]
way more important to them
than the money.
Overton: Yeah.
So...
...what do you think,
Lori?
We'll do the $30,000.
We'll be 1/3 partner.
Our goal is to try to find
somebody to license it.
And then,
when we get to that point,
we'll figure out
what the licensing deal is.
Do you want to take the $30,000
and give up 1/3 of your company?
You got to make a decision.
Yes or no?
♪♪
You are right,
Mr. Wonderful.
It's a lot of my company.
I'd like to make
a counteroffer.
Yeah, Sofi!
Okay.
Let's hear it.
Um...
$35,000 for...
25%.
Wow!
Whoo! Ooh!
[ Laughs ]
Corcoran: Well, well, well.
Sofi's got
negotiating skills!
Greiner: So you're going up...
She had a little switchblade
in her sock on that one, huh?
25%?
♪♪
We will take that offer.
Thank you so much.
Yay!
We're in the sock
business again!
Yes!
John: High five.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm proud of you.
I'm so impressed by you.
Wow.
Congratulations, Sofi.
Well done.
Overton: Thank you.
♪♪
I'm very overwhelmed,
and I'm really excited
that I got a deal
with Lori and Daymond,
and I'm just...
I'm in heaven.
I mean, I'm so excited.
♪♪
Narrator: Next in the Tank
is an island's best‐kept secret
for skin care.
♪♪
Bonjour, Sharks.
My name is Yve‐Car Momperousse.
My name is
Stephane Jean‐Baptiste,
and I'm the lucky honey of
this beautiful woman right here.
We live in
sunny Miami, Florida,
and we are
seeking $400,000
for 10% of our company,
Kreyol Essence.
Sharks,
let's get right to it.
Kreyol Essence has the
liquid gold of the Caribbean,
the most nourishing oil
you'll ever want to use
for your hair,
skin, and body.
We're talking about
a rare beauty secret called ‐‐
Shh!
All: Shh!
...lwil maskriti,
also known as
Haitian castor oil.
Let's show you
how we make liquid gold.
After six months of harvesting,
the best castor seeds
are hand‐selected
by women artisans.
The seeds are then pressed
using a pestle and mortar.
Then they are roasted
and simmered to perfection.
After the oil
has decanted...
Both: Like a fine wine...
...a mesh is used
to filter out any debris,
leaving you with the raw
and pure Haitian castor oil
we all love!
[ Laughs ]
So, whether it's moisturizing
kinky, curly hair,
promoting thicker lashes
or brows,
or relieving
dry, itchy skin,
we have the most high‐performing
natural products for you.
But wait.
Both: There's more!
Kreyol Essence
creates work
for over 300 farmers
and women producers!
[ Cheering ]
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughs ]
So, Sharks,
who's ready to help us build
a billion‐dollar business
and share with the world
the true beauty
that Haiti has to offer?
[ Shouts in Haitian Creole ]
Sharks?
[ All shout in Haitian Creole ]
[ Laughter ]
Merci anpil.
Thank you guys so much.
‐Nicely done, guys.
‐Thank you.
Stephane is now
gonna make sure
that you guys get your own boxes
from the Caribbean
and you get to experience
the liquid gold.
Thank you.
♪♪
So, what you guys have
in your boxes...
Ohh!
...it's a collection of some
of our best sellers.
Lori, you're holding up
right now
is our mango papaya
rum punch.
This smells heavenly.
Yes. It transports you
to the Caribbean.
Wow.
Daymond,
what you have right now,
it's the mango papaya rum punch
body creme for your skin.
Oh, that smells really good.
Greiner: Oh, my gosh.
And you have
Haitian grounded coffee
in the body wash...
It smells so good.
...and it's 100% natural.
Corcoran: Mmm!
And I have to say,
no sticky feel whatsoever.
Exactly.
No sticky feeling, yes.
So, there's a lot of creams
and lotions and things
out on the market.
I'm very curious to know
what makes yours
different or better.
What makes Haitian castor oil
so unique
is a composition
that only the oil has,
which is called
ricinoleic acid.
It's gonna go deeper
into the skin
instead of
sitting on top.
So, this is
particularly important
for those with eczema,
psoriasis,
where they need
lots of hydration.
Is Haitian castor oil different
than regular castor oil?
Is it somehow unique?
So, the way castor oil
is normally processed,
what manufacturers do is,
they use hexene,
they use bleach,
and they use other additives.
Cuban:
I love the fact that you're
hiring people in Haiti, right?
So, if you talked more
about those programs
and what you're doing
there...
Jean‐Baptiste: Absolutely.
So, our supply chain actually
starts directly out of Haiti.
We actually have our own farm,
about 12 hectares,
where we work with the farmers,
they work for us directly,
but then we also work
with cooperatives.
Cooperatives.
Most farmers live on
less than $1 a day.
We are paying double that
to make sure
that anytime they are
coming with castor seeds,
we give
an above‐market price.
Got it. Good.
Okay, so,
what are your sales?
So, we started
the business in 2014.
We did $135,000 in sales.
Okay.
That's not bad.
In 2016, we did $40,000
worth of sales.
Whoa!
What happened?
At the time in 2016,
we were focusing
on actually selling
the castor oil in bulk,
and one of our top clients
actually walked away.
We were still building
the supply chain.
So, you had one client
to represent the majority
of your business?
It was actually
the majority, yes.
So, we decided to pivot.
In 2017, we decided
to go direct‐to‐consumer,
and from there,
our sales jumped to $327,000.
Greiner: Wow.
O'Leary: Okay.
You went into the retail space.
You switched totally.
2018?
What happened last year?
In 2018,
we did $1 million in sales.
And what's
this year look like?
Wow.
Nice.
This year, we project that
we will close at $2 million.
‐Wow.
‐Really?
Why will we have
such a significant jump
in revenue at $2 million?
Mm‐hmm.
So, the reason that we feel that
we're gonna get to $2 million
is that we just secured
a contract
from the largest beauty retailer
in the country, Ulta.
Yeah, and they're
gonna be launching us
in all 1,200 doors.
Do you have a PO on hand?
We have conversations, yeah.
So, we just finished
the contract,
and then we should be getting
the PO in the next few weeks.
How do people know
what this is?
That's a really good
question, Lori.
I would walk by this
and really not know anything.
And that's why we spend
lots of time making sure
that we educate our retail
partners and their staff.
The other thing is
social media.
So, right now,
we have over 100,000 followers
between all
of our social media outlets,
and our customer base ‐‐
they're showing
before‐and‐after pictures,
which we have here that we would
love to show you guys.
This actually
helps grow hair?
Yes.
Well!
[ Laughter ]
It helps
to promote hair growth.
That's what we always say.
We say "promote hair growth."
So, male pattern baldness
is a major issue,
and we have one
of our customers ‐‐
again, unsolicited ‐‐
who started using
our Haitian castor oil,
and in three months,
you could see,
at the crown of his head,
that his hair started to grow.
And by the way,
what does this one jar cost?
So, the retail price
is about $22 for our scented
and $16 for
our original castor oil.
And it costs you
what to make it?
It cost me $2.50
to make it.
Corcoran: Wow.
Will you be profitable
this year?
We are profitable.
What did you make in 2018
on the $1 million?
We did about $300,000
on that.
John: And do you
have any debt now?
We do have debt.
How much?
We do have
$300,000 in debt.
You know, what I love
about this business is you.
Thank you.
You could sell
whatever you want to sell.
[ Laughs ]
Extremely persuasive.
But, interestingly,
it's also what I don't like
about the business.
Your business is
too damn dependent
on you selling the product.
That's just not scalable.
I'm out.
Guys, congratulations
with what you've been
able to accomplish.
I just don't see this
being worth $4 million.
I'm out.
[ Smacks lips ]
All right, so, it's just
such a competitive space,
and I don't have enough
expertise in the beauty space.
I'm out.
Daymond,
I'm sorry to hear that.
Greiner: I have a question.
You showed those pictures
of hair growth.
Mm‐hmm. Mm‐hmm.
Have you done any testing,
any laboratory or trials
or clinicals or anything?
So, clinical testing
is actually part
of the market expanding,
part of what, you know,
we're looking
for the funding for.
But you don't have that.
To me, all it does
is signal a red flag,
because when you put out
anything like that
into the consumer market,
you really have to have
a lot of proof backing that up,
because you don't
have the clinicals.
So I'm sorry ‐‐ I'm out.
But the customers are giving
their experience.
But as a product person
and as a Shark,
there's tons
of fake scam ads.
Absolutely.
And we don't do that.
And we are all victim
to those fake scam ads
because they'll photoshop
our images
and they'll say
that we back that,
and we don't at all.
So, now I have to be
triply careful.
Well, Lori's red flag
might be this character's
greatest attraction.
[ Laughter ]
So, I look at it and say
what you do have is sales ‐‐
a potential
of $2 million in sales
if this works out
with this retailer.
There's a lot of risk
in this thing.
I don't think the business is
worth $4 million today.
I'm sorry.
I'll give you the $400,000.
I want 37%.
Ohh!
♪♪
Narrator: Four Sharks are out.
Kevin is
Stephane and Yve's last chance
to make a deal for
their skin‐care company,
Kreyol Essence.
I'll give you the $400,000,
I want 37%.
Ohh!
Okay, thank you so much
for that offer.
Would you do $400,000
for 20%?
Never. Never.
Never.
This has risks.
All businesses
have risks.
Look,
I'm impressed by you.
Now we're having
a tough‐love discussion.
Mm‐hmm.
It's about money.
I want to make money.
37% is too rich.
No, it isn't.
Can you meet me
in the middle, at 25%?
No.
No, no, no.
Look, you have
to make a decision.
Mm‐hmm.
I'll still have the $400,000
when you walk out that door,
and someone else will
be sitting in front of me.
Yes, and I will still
have that, you know, account
where I'm gonna make
$2 million this year
and go on
to make $5‐, $10‐,
and make sure
that we get to $100 million.
Because that's what businesses
of our rank and size have done,
and I want you
to be part of that.
I get it.
But that is too high.
But this is your moment.
You have to make a decision.
But 37% is way too high.
There's no way
we could give that much.
Everybody says that.
You know, if you don't like it,
don't take it.
Lots of risk.
That's why they call it
the Shark Tank.
♪♪
Jean‐Baptiste:
What are some of your ideas?
What would you do
to essentially help us?
Oh, now you got to
sell yourself?
I don't have to sell myself.
I'm Mr. Wonderful.
I'm not asking you
to sell yourself.
We're having a conversation.
You know what I do?
We're having a tough‐love
conversation.
Tough‐love conversation,
Mr. Wonderful.
All right.
I'll justify myself.
I have $400,000.
You don't.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Make a decision.
Jean‐Baptiste: We recognize
that sales cures all.
Yes.
You know, in 2016,
we were getting ready
to shut down the business
because of having lost that ‐‐
Don't tell me that.
I don't want to hear that.
No, no, for sure.
You're not focusing
on the issue at hand.
$400,000 for 37% ‐‐
yes or no?
♪♪
Stephane,
you are very emotional.
Can you share why?
[ Sighs ]
That time period was
really tough for us, in 2016.
I mean, even to the point
where we almost just
closed the business down.
It challenged
our relationship,
you know, feeling
as if we sort of...
We failed our community.
...failed our community,
failed ourselves.
It's not just about
the great products.
It's about the mission
of helping
to create a blueprint
for poverty alleviation,
which is a huge problem
around the world.
It's my culture.
It's my identity. It's...
[ Sniffles ]
It's everything that my parents
sacrificed to get us here.
I mean,
we shouldn't be here.
♪♪
But you are here,
and you have an offer.
[ Laughs ]
What have you
decided to do?
♪♪
Uh, Mr. Wonderful,
would you be interested ‐‐
thinking through this ‐‐
doing a royalty deal?
♪♪
Royalty?
Yes.
That brings a tear
to my eye.
[ Laughter ]
I'd like to hear
what you have in mind.
15 cents
for every bottle sold.
♪♪
So I don't have any equity?
It's just a royalty?
It's just
a royalty deal.
[ Sighs ]
Tell you what ‐‐
final offer.
I want 25 cents royalty
on every unit sold in perpetuity
and 5% equity,
and you have a deal.
♪♪
You have a deal.
Let's do it.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Corcoran: Wow!
What a turnaround!
I didn't see that coming.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Good luck.
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you.
Corcoran: Wow.
What a surprise twist.
Boy, she's got a lot of fire
in that belly.
We did a royalty deal.
[ Laughs ]
Whoo!
No, I was not expecting
Mr. Wonderful.
So, we were not expecting
[ Laughs ]
Yes.
To be a partner
in a Haitian beauty brand?
Yeah. [ Laughs ]
Not quite what
you think of every day.
But, you know,
Kevin O'Leary surprises you.
Exactly.
♪♪
Narrator: In season 6,
mother and son
Judy and Bobby Edwards
made a deal with Lori Greiner
for their toilet stool,
Squatty Potty.
...squat
in a healthy position
while still enjoying the comfort
of their Western toilet.
Let's see how Squatty Potty
is doing now.
We came on "Shark Tank"
to change the way America poops.
And now Squatty Potty has become
a cultural phenomenon.
With Lori on our team,
we were able to secure buyers
at major retailers,
and it snowballed
into an international,
multi‐million‐dollar company.
I was 67 years old,
and so me and my husband, Bill,
decided we wanted to retire.
We were attracting great offers
to buy the business,
but we weren't quite ready
to part with everything yet.
So we decided on an 8‐figure,
multi‐million‐dollar deal
for half of the business.
I just wanted
to thank Lori Greiner
for coming and attending
the board meeting.
Greiner: This new partnership
has been an excellent move
for Squatty Potty.
I love this.
There are
all these new products,
all this new creativity.
It's taken the brand
to a whole new level.
We've now sold over 4.5 million
Squatty Potties.
Bobby: Squatty Potty's partnered
with over 20 major retailers.
We're also in 20 countries
all over the world.
We've now done $175 million
in sales since "Shark Tank."
Greiner: [ Laughing ]
Oh, my gosh!
This is
insanely beautiful!
Greiner: This is
a dream come true for Judy.
She's built her dream home.
When Judy came into the
Shark Tank with Squatty Potty,
most of the other Sharks
laughed.
They thought it was a joke.
And look ‐‐ today,
it's one of "Shark Tank's"
most successful stories ever.
All: To the good life!
I think what Mom shows is that
at any age, anything's possible.
She was set to retire
at 60 years old, with no funds.
Judy:
Then "Shark Tank" came along
and put our business
in the spotlight.
A lot of times,
we look at each other
and go, "You know what?
This is the American dream."
And we are
so grateful for it.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a product
that helps couples stay in sync.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks. I'm Jenn.
And I'm Ryan.
We are the founders of LoveSync
from Cleveland, Ohio.
We're seeking $100,000
for 10% of our company.
Sharks, imagine this.
You're out on a romantic date
with your significant other.
Great food,
a fine bottle
of O'Leary Merlot,
[ Laughter ]
and there are
no distractions
from enjoying
each other's company.
I think we all know
that nights like this
usually finish
with a happy end.
But what about
those everyday nights
when life gets in the way
and sexy times often becomes
a take‐it or leave‐it
proposition?
Like tonight.
He could be down for
a little dance in the sheets,
but he assumes that she is
exhausted from a stressful day,
lets the moment pass.
Little does he know,
she'd be up for
a quick bed boogie to unwind,
but she is tired,
and she figures
it's gonna take more energy
than she's got tonight
to distract him
away from his work.
The reality is,
these types of situations
play out more often
than people realize.
What if there was a way
we could know
our partner's subtle desires
when they're not
always made obvious?
Now there is.
The LoveSync button lets
you and your partner know
when your moods
are matched,
turning missed opportunities
into more romance.
It works like this.
Simply place a button
at each nightstand
and plug in the power.
On those routine evenings
where she's feeling
a little frisky,
she discreetly
taps her button.
If she's the only one
who taps...
[ Laughs ]
...her partner
never knows.
She enjoys her sleep.
But...
he's also a tad randy.
He'll discreetly
tap his button.
The LoveSync technology
recognizes
they're both privately thinking
the same thing.
It lets them know
by emitting a swirling glow
from the buttons.
They can now make their moves
with confidence...
[ Laughter ]
...knowing their partner's
good to go.
[ Laughter ]
With LoveSync, couples' desires
are fulfilled more frequently,
leading to
a happier relationship.
Isn't it time for those of us
already in relationships
to have a little tech
to help us hook up more?
So, Sharks, who of you
want to get in bed with us
and help get the world
LoveSynced?
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Nice.
Not what I was expecting.
We're gonna go ahead
and excuse our couple
for a little private time.
[ Laughs ]
Barbara, Kevin,
go test it.
[ Laughter ]
So, why did you
come up with this?
One night, I was laying there
on the fence, like,
"If I knew it wasn't gonna be
a lot of work tonight,
if she's, like, down,
ready to go,"
I'm like,
"I'd go for it."
[ Chuckles ] God.
And I don't know ‐‐
that's when it struck,
and it was just
one of those ideas.
So, Jenn...
[ Chuckles ]
what do you think of this?
Once I got it,
it was like a light‐bulb moment.
After using the buttons now
for several months,
it's a gadget that
we don't want to get rid of.
We've gotten a lot of feedback
from our backers
who have said
they didn't even realize
the opportunities
that they were missing
until they got
the button.
What are your sales?
We made $25,000
on Kickstarter.
And that's how many units?
That was 400 units.
Have you fulfilled
all the orders on Kickstarter?
Yes. Yes.
Yes.
What do you sell it for?
Around $60.
Wow.
That's not bad.
People pay a lot more
for a dozen roses
to get the same thing.
[ Greiner laughs ]
What do they cost to make?
So, at our first demo queue
of 1,000 units, we're at $22.
Oh, wow.
That'll go down
to $14 or less.
Greiner: Share with us
your background,
because is this
your full‐time job?
No.
So, I, um...
I'm a chief product engineer.
I work on consumer robotics ‐‐
actually, robotic lawn mowers.
I am
the operations manager
for a marriage and family
counseling practice.
Well, that would make sense,
you know?
Mm‐hmm.
We know that the future in this
is with mobile.
We are currently developing
a mobile app.
I'm having a hard time
with the basic premise.
I mean, what about you
two guys? Why don't you
just talk to each other?
"Look, I want some sex.
You in or out?"
We do,
but here's the problem.
LoveSync is going to make
communicating romantically
easier
and more efficient.
That's what technology
has done for us
in all other aspects
of our lives.
What I was sitting here thinking
was the exact opposite.
Yeah.
So many people complain today
that, actually,
technology and people
being on their phones
and not communicating
has become, like, overpowering
and actually a bad thing.
I don't see this
as sexy or romantic.
I see it
as technology going too far ‐‐
like, to a place
where I feel like
just communicating is
so much more important.
I'm so sorry.
I don't believe in this.
So ‐‐
I'm out.
So, it is not
a replacement.
There is some science
about this.
Our sexual desire ranges
on a spectrum,
from ice‐cold,
like, "It's just not happening
right now," right,
to red‐hot,
"I'm gonna let you know
what I'm thinking.
I'm gonna communicate."
You're gonna get
your point across,
and you're communicating.
Do that.
Are you saying the motivation
is the fear of rejection?
Yeah.
So, this is why the app ‐‐
This is why we are pivoting
the hardware ‐‐
I hate the app idea.
There are millions of apps
sitting on platforms
that never get used.
If you had the app working
right now
and you put it out there...
Do any of them
get you more sex?
...you would have to get
customers acquired.
That would require capital
to figure out,
"What's my customer
acquisition cost?"
whether it's this button
or whether it's an app.
And, you know,
I think there's
a fair amount of skepticism
up here about this,
to be honest with you.
I think it would work, right,
for enough people.
But this is a business.
You haven't said anything at all
about the business,
other than
you've done a Kickstarter,
but that doesn't tell me
you have anything to invest in.
Here's the business.
So, once we launch
the app,
we will start growing
our user base ‐‐
slowly at first,
to start to get feedback,
and ‐‐ and, uh...
Ryan, that's not an answer,
right?
You're stumbling
all over it.
So, then it's gonna be
a subscription model because...
O'Leary: This is the app now?
...obviously,
people are skeptical about this.
This is not the buttons?
Now we're on the app?
That's right.
Like I said, the app is
the future of this,
and I will tell you
why that is.
[ Groans ]
So, anybody out there
who's thinking, like,
"That's a dumb idea" ‐‐
What happened
to the button?
There's always
a piece of ‐‐
We're not gonna sell
any buttons?
Let's try. It could be fun.
Let's see what happens.
Ryan,
you're all over the map!
You know, Ryan ‐‐
So ‐‐
Ryan ‐‐ Ryan, you're making
things more confusing.
Okay.
Ryan, I'm out.
I just can't see you getting
from point "A" to point "B."
I don't think you're organized
enough to make this work.
John:
So, here's my thought on it.
My favorite part
of my relationship with my wife
is talking crap all day about
all the things I'm gonna do,
and then I just fall asleep ‐‐
I don't even do anything.
And I've heard it.
He's truthful.
But that's the romantic part,
right?
You know,
she knows that I love her,
she knows
that I'm attracted by her,
and I'm like, "Oh,
I'm‐a do this, I'm‐a do this,"
and she's like, "Sure, buddy.
You're not doing anything."
And that's the beautiful
part about it.
So, I think it's a little
too early right now for me.
I'm out.
Mark, I'd like to ‐‐
Corcoran:
I want to give this a shot
if I could, okay?
The price point is too high,
the cost to make it is too high,
but here's the real problem
with your business plan.
It's Ryan.
And I'm gonna tell you, Ryan,
why you're a problem.
You don't listen.
You're so in love
with your idea
that you're tripping
over yourself
to express your love
again and again,
and you really haven't
adequately answered
any objection
that has been raised here.
You jump‐skipped
onto your new app.
That's a problem.
Because the entrepreneurs
that don't listen never make it.
I don't care what kind of
product they have in their hand.
And so that is
the scariest thing in the world
and the scariest place in
the world for me to put money.
So, sadly, as much as I actually
like what you've done here,
I'm out for that reason.
O'Leary: Guys, I'm sorry.
You did a poor job
presenting.
I'm out.
♪♪
‐Good luck, guys.
‐All right.
‐Bye, guys. Good luck.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Uh‐huh.
♪♪
Jenn:
We are so excited
about this product
and this technology
and all the ideas
that we have for it.
I think we let that
get the best of us,
and we weren't effective enough
in communicating
the plan that we actually have
to do that.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an entrepreneur's obsession
turned into a business.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks.
My name is Melissa Bartow.
I'm from New York City,
and I'm seeking $100,000
for 20% of my company,
Wanna Date?
I had my first date just
three years ago during college,
and let me tell you, I've had
a lot of dates ever since.
At least a few every day.
Sometimes even more.
Sharks, I love dates so much
that I created...
[ Greiner laughs ]
...Wanna Date?
Corcoran: Ohh!
A line of date‐based spreads
that are natural, vegan,
and ‐‐ get this ‐‐
they're totally allergen‐free.
You see, Sharks,
dates are
my absolute favorite fruit.
These tasty little things
satisfy all my cravings,
power me
through my workout...
Damn.
Nice.
...and keep me energized
all day long.
I love dates so much
that I want to just spread them
on everything.
And the best part is
that my date spreads
come with all of
your favorite flavors ‐‐
chocolate, vanilla, cinnamon,
and let's not forget
pumpkin spice,
and at just 30 calories
per serving,
Wanna Date? is
the perfect go‐to alternative
for any nut, butter,
or syrup out there.
So, Sharks,
no more cheating on your diets.
What do you all say?
Wanna Date?
John: Wanna Date?
Greiner:
We'd love to try it.
Yes!
I know you could all use
a little more love
in your lives, so samples!
Absolutely.
♪♪
All right.
For Daymond.
Here you are.
Thank you.
That's a big tray of food.
Greiner: Thank you.
Do you have, just,
a natural date,
or they're all flavored?
All flavors.
Cuban: A shame
you didn't get us enough food.
Greiner: [ Laughing ]
Yeah, really.
John: Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, Melissa.
Appreciate it.
Bartow: You are welcome.
God. There's enough food
to last a lifetime.
Greiner: Wow. Oh, yum.
Corcoran: What is this ‐‐
yogurt base?
That is an acai bowl
with mixed berries on top
and chocolate date spread
drizzled.
Next to that
is a bowl of overnight oats
sweetened only with
vanilla Wanna Date?,
a stack of pumpkin spice
Wanna Date? pancakes,
and then a date butter
and banana sandwich
with cinnamon Wanna Date?
and a side
of cinnamon date spread bacon.
So delicious.
I like them,
but it tastes so sweet.
Are you sure it's only
30 calories per serving?
Dates typically have
a lot of calories.
Yes.
So, if you think about it,
most jams and jellies
are actually 40 or 50,
nut butters are actually
80 to 90 calories.
Plus, we don't add any oils.
We mix with water.
O'Leary: Here's a fact, Melissa,
you may not know.
The date fruit,
along with camel milk,
can sustain a human being
indefinitely.
That's how many Bedouins
centuries ago
lived in the desert.
Greiner: How do you
know this story?
Corcoran:
Remarkable you know that.
Because I know.
Camel milk?
What people don't understand
about the date,
it's one of the healthiest
fruits on Earth,
and, actually,
it's lower cal than many fruits.
No, the dates
are a superfood.
I tell everyone dates are
the next, like, avocados...
It is a superfood.
...or cauliflower
in terms of food trends.
Ah, super, schmuper.
They're delicious
but so under‐utilized.
Tell us about your sales
and how you're selling them.
So, it's been about 10 months.
To date, I've sold ‐‐
"To date." [ Chuckles ]
[ Laughs ]
...just under $31,000.
10% of that's been
through my website,
and then
35% is through events.
I go to Christmas markets
around New York City
on the weekends,
vegan fairs.
And 55% is wholesale.
Melissa, tell us about you.
Originally, I'm from
just northwest Georgia,
a town called Kennesaw,
and I just graduated from NYU,
actually, three weeks ago.
Cuban: Congrats.
Are you working on this
100% of the time?
Yes.
Because $31,000 in sales,
living in New York City...
How do you support yourself?
My dad supports me still.
So, how much does
one jar cost you to make?
Right now,
it costs me $2.40 to make,
Cuban: Ooh.
with the label and all.
That's a lot.
I sell it ‐‐ Excuse me?
Yes.
I can get costs down, though,
to about $1.70 or $1.80.
And what do you sell it for?
On my website, for $12.
Greiner: $12?
Yes.
And people are willing
to pay $12 a jar?
Yes. I've actually
never had anyone complain
about $12 per jar.
Really?
Yeah.
Did you do any type
of market research, though,
where you would, like,
reach out to people
and ask them,
"Would you buy this?
How often would you use it?" ‐‐
things like that.
Um...not formally.
But also, I've learned people
have no idea what they do want.
You know?
Amen.
The challenge with that is,
you're there, right?
And you're educating them,
right?
When I first started,
I used to stand out
on 125th Street in Harlem,
right outside the Apollo
when the Apollo Theater let out,
and I got
really good responses.
They told me what they thought
about my T‐shirts and my mama.
Everything.
[ Laughter ]
But then, when I went
to put it in stores,
it didn't move.
When nobody was there
to tell the story,
I got stuck.
So, I think
it's a crowded market
that I know nothing about,
and I think it's gonna
be a challenge, really,
just educating people
on how badly they need this.
So I'm out.
Okay.
I feel like
it's very early
for us to know
if people want dates or not.
It was delicious.
I wish you good luck...
Can I ‐‐
...but I'm gonna go out.
Well, I hope
you change your mind.
I'm gonna make dates
mainstream
the same way avocados
and cauliflower ‐‐ everything.
That's why I chose flavors
to lower the inhibitions
of customers who have
never had dates, heard of dates,
don't know
the health benefits.
But, Melissa, why didn't you do
just a plain flavor
for people
who like dates?
So, I do have, actually ‐‐
I just developed a plain flavor.
Well, why the flavors at all
to start?
If you're gonna turn dates
into a superfood,
you got to let
the star of the show
be the star of the show.
So, where are you going
with this, Mark?
I'm disappointed
in some respects.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
And Mark has an issue
with the line of flavors
of Melissa's date butter
company, Wanna Date?
The plain flavor's coming.
I know,
but would you do just that?
And abandon all the flavors?
For right now, yeah.
Because if you want
to make it a superfood,
make it
the star of the show.
Here's where, for me,
it falls apart.
When I was starting
my business,
if I didn't make a deal
within two weeks, I was dead.
I needed to live somewhere
and eat.
What is in your way,
I believe,
is that your father
is helping you,
because succeeding is an option,
versus a necessity.
And I found that the people
that really succeed
have a real necessity.
They have to do it
or the sky's gonna fall in.
With the absence of that,
I can't believe it enough
to put my money in,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
♪♪
Well...I won't be homeless
if this fails,
but I do everything
on my own.
[ Voice breaking ]
I've ‐‐ I run my web‐‐
Sorry.
Like, my dad
just believes in me.
You know, like, I'm...
I'm...
I've never had anything
handed to me in my whole life.
I'm not, like, a rich kid.
I don't sleep.
I carry cases of this
all over New York.
I work events.
I do them all myself.
Nobody helps me.
But take away
that security blanket
of having your rent paid,
and the comparison would be,
like, night and day
what you can accomplish.
I've seen it over and over again
with so many people.
Failure's just when you quit.
I don't quit,
so this won't fail,
'cause I will go
until it succeeds.
John:
Listen, I started out,
and my mother
mortgaged the house.
And without her
mortgaging the home,
I couldn't have financed
my first couple of shirts.
So, I mean,
that's Barbara's opinion.
You know what, Melissa,
I don't agree.
I understand
from an investment perspective.
There is value when someone's
back is against the wall.
We've all faced it, right?
But that's like saying,
if Barbara's right,
that means none of our kids can
ever do anything on their own,
and I can't ‐‐
I refuse to believe that.
Like, I hate
asking him for money,
and this is the first time
I've ever had to.
[ Sniffles ] And I'm gonna
pay him every single penny back.
That's why I work hard
every day.
Melissa, my problem
with your deal is...
it's too early to be worth
half a million bucks.
There's a lot
that's going to happen
before you actually get scale.
And I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
♪♪
So, now
there's me and you.
Do you have competition?
Is there anybody else
selling date butter?
The closest thing is one
that's full of coconut oil,
coconut butter.
It's 10 times the calories.
It has fat,
it has cholesterol.
I just went vegetarian,
so I'm always looking
for things that are healthy,
healthy for my family.
Absolutely.
When you walked in,
and other than thinking "What
the hell is this?" initially,
the idea of a date spread
was great,
'cause I love dates.
But you got to be smaller,
cheaper, easier to ship,
and you have to make dates
just plain.
Are you willing
to do all that?
Absolutely. We can look into
other packaging options.
Absolutely.
Okay.
So I'll make you an offer.
♪♪
$100,000,
but I want 33%.
33%?
Right.
Because it's gonna
take some time,
it's gonna take
some effort.
But there you go.
That's your offer.
You got an offer.
What do you want to do?
Because I've learned
that it never hurts to ask ‐‐
No.
No?
Greiner: Oh, my God.
Well, he answered already.
You can counter.
Do it.
Go with your gut.
This is your business.
Just tell Mark Cuban
to take a walk.
♪♪
I'll take it.
I want to work with you.
[ Laughter ]
I'll take 33% for $100,000.
Ta‐da!
Thank you, Mark!
O'Leary: Smart move, Melissa.
Smart move.
Greiner: Congratulations.
I appreciate it.
I'm excited.
O'Leary: Smart move.
Thank you, everyone.
Greiner: Congratulations.
‐Good luck.
‐We'll talk soon.
♪♪
Oh, my God.
I've been an underdog
my whole life.
Barbara not believing in me
is just one
in another million people,
and I always prove
everyone wrong.
I just work harder.
I put my head down and hustle,
and I'll just keep doing that.
It's what I've always done
and always will do.
Did you notice,
after I insulted her,
she was
a different person?
I like the way
you beat her up.
Greiner: Yeah.
That's what I wanted to see,
if she had what it took.
I think Mark brought up a point.
Why did you insult her?
Because none of our kids
will be successful because ‐‐
No. You know why? Because
there are a lot of wealthy kids
that become
extremely successful,
and I expect it
of my children.
But until I insulted her,
I wasn't feeling her vibe.
Boy, she fought back,
and that was the difference.
She came back like a fighter.
That's what I want to see.
♪♪